la situación política en mianmar parece
estar lejos de solucionarse luego de dos
semanas del golpe militar miles de
ciudadanos siguen saliendo a las calles
para exigir la vuelta de la democracia y
desafían al poder del ejército
quiero que más gente se una a las
protestas no queremos que nos vean
débiles
nosotros los estudiantes tenemos nuestro
futuro tenemos que resistir para no
vivir bajo una dictadura militar
la junta ha negado que su acción del
pasado 1 de febrero sea un golpe de
estado y se ha comprometido a devolver
el poder una vez se realicen nuevas
elecciones sin embargo la socavación de
derechos democráticos fundamentales ha
sido constante en estas semanas durante
las últimas dos noches que internet fue
cortado para los ciudadanos y se han
hecho con el control de los bancos
imponiendo este martes un límite de
retiro que ha generado caos entre muchos
birmanos a esto se suman las numerosas
detenciones
entenderíamos una represión si fuéramos
violentos
ahora no podemos aceptar una represión
por estar protestando pacíficamente
los principales líderes políticos entre
los que está aún sang soo choo siguen
arrestados de hecho el abogado de la
lideresa birmana aseguró que los
militares le acusaron con un nuevo cargo
que es la violación del artículo 25
utilizado para enjuiciar a aquellos que
no cumplen con las restricciones a causa
del coronavirus esto podría detener
indefinidamente su juicio y llevarla a
prisión por hasta tres años